you met someone and this happens
sometimes when you have a very because
you got when someone's a fan of yours
sometimes they take it almost too far
you met someone who's got a Rea tattoo
of your face on their body is that right
yeah how'd you meet this person I was at
Chipotle these stories always end up
well for Chipotle and and and it was
lunchtime because my daughter really
wanted a burrito whatever adored the
salad and he says the manager comes out
it's filled with people and they're
saying oh my gosh your biggest fan this
year so wow that's old nice and now
people are starting to tune in
he says he's such a big fan of yours
he's got he's got a tattoo of you as a
kid a day he's got a tattoo I mean
that's crazy and and and he said you
know he's here I said the guy with the
tattoo of me is here yeah now now
everyone's listening everyone's watching
yes well where is he bringing him bring
him out I want to see this a tattoo of
me and there was a tattoo of me and if
I'm Goodfellas and Pesci and De Niro
let's see you took a picture of it now I
have a question
[Applause]
did that guy make that himself that book
first of all that's Christopher Walken
on the right
I think that's John F Kennedy hub front
which one is a oh that's supposedly the
one on the right but maybe now we know
where they're in trouble
please tell me that's his shoulder all
right so listen speaking of Goodfellas I
was it was just the 25th anniversary of
Goodfellas and I was saying before he
came out one of my maybe top ten films
of all time ever made I love that movie
I never knew that you were not maybe the
first choice but the producers or
whoever was in charge of the studio to
play Henry Hill is that right oh yeah
they would have rather have Eddie Murphy
than me right anybody else anybody
different because I had only done Field
of Dreams hadn't come out yet I had done
two movies that nobody saw they were
good movies and from what I understand
Marty wanted Morris's Scorsese director
wanted me and then but they were having
trouble getting Warner Brothers to say
yes and then from what I understand De
Niro saw Marty at a party they were
talking they were talking about he was
having trouble finding the character to
play Jimmy Burke that the the part that
that Bob eventually played and when De
Niro said he would do it I guess that
was what the studio needed to hear and
then it was pressure off of we need a
big star who you know right there for
that rule exactly Tom Cruise was
considered for your part ah that's what
I heard
really oh sorry I thought that was a
well-known fat
it worked out Rea it worked out your new
show shades of blue it is as we said
it's it's a network show but it's quite
an edgy show I mean it's pretty amazing
what you can get away with on television
just what you were saying before blew my
mind what didn't you say [ __ ]
wouldn't talk that way on television I
heard what shall we are you watching
backstage it's his pet name for me that
was in a commercial break I say to Andy
you pipe down [ __ ] you're supposed to
paint that on television you get things
straight [ __ ] I'm in charge here yes
it is amazing you were you work with
with with Jennifer Lopez Jennifer Lopez
do you call her JLo unless she calls me
reloj I will not go
[Applause]
you don't you don't go for that nickname
I know actually I've done two other
movies one with it's even hard to say
now when with Busta Rhymes and one with
LL Cool J and I just I'm not I'm just
not gonna call him by those nicknames
you mean you're not gonna say to a grown
man
yeah well yo gay I just want to hear
what you call you didn't say buster
III write to him I was mr. Buster but I
won't do it alright hey thanks for
watching please subscribe to my youtube
channel so they will stop making me
shoot these videos please